- There's many ways to be known
and to get success and be successful.
It's just about picking
the way that fits you.
- You've got to think outside the box,
because that's the only way
you're going to get out.
- People around me they don't
see the moves that you make.
So they going to tell you everything
that you should of did, could of did,
but it's not part of your vision.
You'll get thrown off, you got
to always stick to your vision
no matter what.
- He's an American rapper, singer,
songwriter, and record producer.
In February 2017, he
became the first artist
to launch two albums consecutively
and have them go to number
one on the Billboard 200.
He's also released several singles
certified gold or higher, by the RIAA.
He's Future and here's my take
on his top 10 rules of success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'm curious to figure out which one
you guys like the best.
Also guys as you're watching
if you hear something to
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in
the comments down below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
by your sharing, and also
when you write it down
you're much more likely to
lock it in for yourself too.
Enjoy.
- Hustle mean no sleep,
you know what I'm sayin',
take flights, do shows,
get back on another flight,
do a photo shoot, do some
interviews, it's not easy,
going on the road putting in work.
There's so many things going
on in your personal life
at times you get a little shaky.
Just not being able to
be with my kids as much,
being around my family.
So you got to always be
driven by your hustle,
and just continue to grind.
Every day's not going to be pretty,
everything's not going to
be glamorous, so to speak.
You got to stay consistent
and stay productive.
Everyday you got to work hard.
I'm most comfortable when
I'm in in the studio.
Nothing else matters but the music.
You've got this love for it.
It's something that you think about.
You sleep or you dream, and
you wake up and you breathe it
and you want to live it.
There's so many options,
there's many ways to blow up,
there's many ways to be known,
and to get success and to be successful.
It's about picking the way that fits you.
Man, statistics said if I did that
and stopped going to
school and that's all I did
was hang in the hood, that I
wasn't going to be here today.
That's why I still hang
with the same people
that I was with back in the
hood and I changed my mentality.
I don't think the same way
I was when I was there.
I opened my mind up, I thought broader.
I thought outside of my horizons.
You got to think outside the box,
because that's the only way
you're going to get out.
When you're trapped in the trap,
you're really mentally
trapped in the trap.
It's me like man I want
to make sure my people
just know that that's just
not the end of your life.
If somebody tells you these statistics.
It's not you, you're
going to fight statistics
and go to the next level.
Statistics said that I
wouldn't even be here
talking to you right now.
If I would have listened to them
and tell them how my life would've been.
They say one out 10 people,
they're going to be like this,
or nine out of 10 black
males, if they do this,
live this way, they're going to do this.
You know what I'm saying?
There's no way around it.
They're going to tell you
there's no way around.
So if you're in the hood right now,
you're standing on the block every day.
Them police just riding by,
the old lady that's looking at you,
that's calling the police on you.
The people who are riding
by just looking at you
like, "They ain't nothing,
their pants sagging."
They think that you ain't
never going to be nothing.
They think you're going to be like that
for the rest of your life.
Who is the person to tell
you that you're going
be standing on this block all your life.
It's supposed to be a part of your life
where you'll on be here for,
you give yourself a year or two.
You from here,
it don't do no good for you
to be here all your life.
You spend the majority of your life,
22 hours out of your day,
trying to prove that you're
the hardest in the hood.
You come from this, you was born in this,
you came home from the
hospital you went to the hood.
You know what I'm saying?
So you're going to live your whole life
this way for all your life.
You deserve to live in a
different neighborhood,
to better yourself, for three, four years,
or your whole life you've
been living this way.
Probably some dude been
living that way for 20 years,
23 years, been in the hood
since they came home from the hospital.
They still trying to prove to the hood
how hard they is, and not making it.
They never proved to themselves,
You've got to prove to yourself
that you want more than
the hood has to offer.
Everything I do I freestyle.
So sometimes I get the freestyle
and play it back and come back and fix it.
Make it do what it do.
Everything I've ever done I freestyled.
A lot of people don't know
that, but that's how I get made.
You got to keep working at it,
and then work and work and work.
The first one might not be right.
The second, the tenth
one, the fifteenth one
might not be right, but
you know what I'm saying,
you're going to get it right.
You got to keep going and going.
Until you get it out and
say what you want to say.
At the end of day when
I, for my first song,
when I first made it in my
head, I knew what I could do.
I know the type of artist that I am.
I know the caliber of
music that I can come with.
I know that I can continue to do it.
I was born to make music.
When you got a gift for something
you just got to know how to utilize it.
When I found out the way to utilize it,
or to make the most of my opportunity,
I know I have to be, I'm an artist.
I have to stay in the studio
and create all the time.
If I was to lay off and
not go to the studio
then all those, he say, she
say, might would have come true.
I know the work that I was putting in.
Just reinvent, because every
album Rico always said,
man you got to reinvent
yourself, reinvent yourself.
So by the time when Southern play listed,
when they was rocking Like the Braves,
they already knew where they was going
the next time they was coming.
Dre already knew what he wanted to do.
It sounds like this, he
wanted to dress like this.
So next time he knew what he wanted.
Naw, I don't want to rap on this album,
I want to just straight
sing and do my production.
Or I want to rap, I don't
want to do no shows.
Every chance, every time you
come, you reinvent yourself.
Give the fans something new.
I never gave up for a moment.
Even when other people gave
up on different moments,
it might feel like damn
why you make that move?
It's like, shit, is just
I gave it away I wrote it.
How would you write a song,
why it won't be your song,
but a choice for my vision
where I'm at right now.
You said it then when he
was getting more money
for a show than me.
I felt like, I did all the
work, but I didn't let that
energy get in the way of what I was doing.
The people around me
they don't see the moves
that you make, so
they're going to tell you
everything that you should
have did, could have did.
But it's not a part of your vision.
You got to throw it off.
You've got to always stick to
your vision no matter what.
If you wrote it down when you was a kid
you got to stick to that vision.
You can't get your hands on some money
and be like I want to change it up now.
That's where you got your vision,
you've got to keep with
whatever got you good.
The key to success is like ...
When you haven't been successful,
you don't know what the key
to success or happiness,
or how to be successful.
You know the right moves.
You're making every move that your making,
and you're striving, and you
just achieve a certain thing.
That you make goals for yourself,
you set goals, and you'll achieve goals.
At the end of the day you
still only reach so high.
For when you reach a certain plateau,
you got to go to that next level.
You want to be successful,
success is giving for other people.
Success for me is just making music.
Success, being successful is
just like winning a Grammy.
You know those things that
are in the back of your mind?
You should be able to live life free.
Free of anything that's
going to get in the way
of hindering you from
getting your prosperity.
I don't focus on the media,
I focus on the great things in life,
I focus on everything I've overcome
to be the person that I am today.
I focus on the positive.
I focus on achieving my goals.
I focus on dreaming, you
got to live with no remorse.
You got to create your own
path, you know what I mean?
No matter what situation you're in.
Rich, poor, whatever, however.
You just want to be able to
have your own experiences
in life, and listen and learn
from other people's mistakes.
So you don't have to walk down
and make the same mistakes.
Some people are just hard headed,
they want to make the same mistakes,
so they can say they did it.
Just create your own path
man, just do enjoy it.
Everything that I'm living the way I live
is the way I wanted to live my life.
It ain't somebody, somebody in my family,
the way they was living.
I pretty much create my own vibe.
I create my path, create my success story.
My success story, it's not
the best success story,
but in a success story as
long as you've got success,
it's cool, you know what I mean?
You got bumps in the roads
you got to get through.
You got mistakes,
but for the most part you
got to know how to be able
to maneuver and get through it.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Jose Nunez asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to
profile next, leave it down
in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know what did Future say
that had the biggest impact on you.
What video clip resonated
the most with you,
and what immediate action
are you going to take
in your life or your business
after watching this video?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Rajveer Dhanak.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really really really means a lot to me.
I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- Originality and consistency.
Even though I had all those records,
I had probably 10 records on the radio
and they still didn't give
me no awards or nothing.
Like I had Love Song,
Bugatti, Good Cushion Alcohol,
when I wrote this song for Body Floridee,
and I had probably Same Damn Time
or Neva End with Kelly Rowland
on the radio, all at the same time.
None of these records even got an award
or even went up for an award.
- You mean like Grammy?
- [Future] Because it's like I'm cheating.
- It's like you what?
- It's like I'm cheating.
There's no way you can
have all these records.
So they're just not going to give it to me
because it comes too easy to me.
So they're making me work for it.
That's how I want it.
- How do you do it,
how do you write a hit?
- I write so many songs,
I do 10 songs a day,
and it just, not every
song is the same song.
- All 10, do you have
to kind of write some
and it doesn't work and you,
- Some of it don't work,
sometimes I never finish it,
sometimes it might be just a verse.
Sometimes it might be a hook,
but I just continue to work.